yo is wild 9041 man Ready Set Radio in
studio right now this guy is man making
a ton of noise he got ripped off from
that double XL cover yeah we got ripped
off we talked about that last time he
was here but you did see him in that BT
cyber drop the number two I'm in the
country these things happen we got my
dog gez about here man I'm in Florida
the boys here young Gerald is here um
man so you're on this tour and we were
just talking like half the tour he 40
was was on it with you being like a dude
from the bay to have a 40 on your tour
and I wanna say you opened up for you
but like oh god mine yeah yeah yeah I'm
saying like how did that feel I just
sharing the tour with somebody I'm
idolized my life looked up to a legend
it's a blessing it's an honor to get to
share that kind of opportunity man and
um you know it's just been crazy like I
always think about it let me put
together a tour it is who do you want to
be around every day for you know what I
mean all you guys do well yeah yeah who
do you want to watch perform and who you
you know what I mean but also it's like
that's from a personal selfish side like
I'd rather watch e47 every night didn't
you know but um I was trying to you know
if you're putting the tour together make
a statement and you know again since I
was a kid it's like you know been a
dream to say like I'm going to take this
worldwide and represent this Bay Area
shed you know I mean and and just take
it around the world and um it's that
it's like I'm on tour with that
ambassador yeah you wanna and we're
going around waving a flag and just you
know from the bay to the Tampa Bay you
know we're out here I never said now I
know like your music is is I feel like a
lot of the stuff you say is like so I
was anybody who asked me about your
music they haven't heard like man she
easy is like he just be saying some fly
like how much I know you know obviously
you're influenced by all the Bay Area
MCS and stuff but but where were some
your other
coming from nas was always been one of
my favorite rappers a lot of time though
Maddox body you know most like listen to
my two influential a I'm sure a lot of
people I share that New York state of
mind to me is a great song hammer yeah a
half time for me on that one is this but
not a lot of East Coast hip hop like
Tribe Called Quest Midnight Marauders
one of my other favorite albums of all
time
Jadakiss is actually one of my favorite
rappers just oh yeah and then you know
obviously Lil Wayne and Drake and Kanye
is like you know really don't I on the
all-time probably number one I gradient
yeah that's crazy so it's like it's
almost like a perfect fusion is really a
pop get out area stuff yeah yeah
the bear is you know and that's what
something what has been the craziest cuz
you know we just told you we had some
chick who said that she would give you
fellatio of you to be a man what is out
here underneath the the the mixing board
what's the craziest light yo yo fan you
got some super fans and I hear you're
like you know there's like people who
have crazy fans like ICP but they're all
like fat ugly yeah yeah but like your
fan sir for the most part very
attractive yeah you know and I mean you
know think about it like I don't know um
what's the craziest like interaction
that you had with the other day with
what city was it I want to say it was
Albuquerque or was it was in Santa Ana
was it Santa Cruz I think was senator
sanders I think it was one of the
Santa's it was on the west coast and um
I mean usually you know a few will get
thrown whatever but all of a sudden it
just started raining bras and a couple
hitting it was rainin like I
didn't even see him coming it was just
from every single angle um
that's always that's always wild and
weird having people just like wait
outside the bus and just like you know I
mean
we're and crazies are you indulging in
this part of your career right now lady
gotta take like after coming out in
living like eight years from now you
might you know be there play you got to
get it all out man yeah yeah yeah but in
ten years I hope to still be here man
it's like I always try to keep
perspective you know and enjoy the
moment but it's tough man because it's
like I feel like we've been clouded for
so long and this is like ten years in
but at the same time we're only
scratching the surface now and I'm
constantly reminded like we went out
with Drake and when we do get like that
tour and you know if you ever need a
reminder how big the mountain is it's
like you open for those guys and you
know you get out there in front of a
crowd that's there for them and you know
you get out there you do your best you
put on the show you convince who you can
you know you mean you kill it but then I
watch Titus days and I watch them play
and oh my god you know I mean like it's
so far to go so you just think about the
long term the big picture the grand
scheme you know yeah how was that like
because I know that that first like
opening slot on those arena shows can be
tough because as a lot of people are
like just getting there and eleven seven
this one was different so I did the
Wayne tour last summer and I was like
the first of six acts that is really I
was going on that toy yeah and it was
you know it was a look for me at the
time when I was a you know a hell of
opportunity this one they only have one
opener at night and I got a full set so
when I went on the place was usually
already pretty packed and I would play
right up until when they played so it
was a great you know great opportunity
I'm just not get out there in front of
people
um we talked early like like last time
you were here I was trying to get you to
let me know if you're gonna be
like cell cover because I thought you
were like a shoo-in I listen there's no
way gee there's like three or four guys
that gotta make it this year yeah you
know they let not matter you got the
number two albums yeah which you know
you that's good you know but um
what but like like when stuff like that
happens is that something is that
something motivates you of course of
course I'd be lying if I said it didn't
I think anybody that works hard in
anything whether it's creative or
whether you're you know I don't know
just out there doing construction or
something like that or any kind of job
that you you put your all into some kind
of validation yeah you know feels good
and of course you know stuff like that
like awards or covers or whatever little
like little accolades yeah like yeah
that's the word I was looking for you
know those are those are forms of
validation but but for me you know it's
like I kind of felt like outsider like
an underdog forever since I was a little
kid you know I mean like um never quite
fitting in anywhere being the one on
that you know what I mean like so it was
just another another little chip on my
shoulder you know so then when the album
came out I was all accolades I needed it
was like the fans are out there you know
it's over 120 KDOT the tours I was
courting haven't had a show that hasn't
sold out yet I'm out here touring with
you know what I mean my OG my legend I
grew up listening to and now you just
try to take the take the good and just
you know they main appreciate that
aspect of it and know that like now you
can't please everybody and you know I'm
good so I'm not here you know I know
you've been doing your thing for a while
man and and I know that like I always
feel like there's like like in this new
age of guys who are kind of built their
following up before they take that major
deal you got like core fans that like
you know your day one fancy and I always
see like a lot of my homies like once
they start getting popping and doing
stuff
yeah Rick Ross in French Montana yeah
you can like any bike back from yogurt
your like ogee fans like that uh yeah I
mean I think the bike rack comes when
the music sucks right you know a lot of
people a lot of people get it twisted
and they're like oh you know he he
signed his deal he sold out he changed
to an artist that they've been following
from grassroots and you know that
happens when the music changes right
when the music sucks when you let the
label tell you you need to do this pop
record right here you know and it's like
I kept creative control in my deal and
that was what my line in the sand was is
creative control and you know it's still
on my terms
so my music starts to suck down I mean
and yet even then it's on me don't write
I mean it's not it's not some you know
executive telling me pushing or a record
to this like people look at me like I
son but that's that'll never happen
because I just care so much about the
music and you know that's what put us
here is like that attention and detail
just you know that effort towards the
craft like that's you know I think
sometimes people get so swept up in the
lifestyle or like you know the return
that they forget about the process and
that's what's important is to you know
be in love with this for the right
reasons and being in love with the work
and the process and the music and that's
what puts you down before you like I
know like you guys are so your whole
kambrose like so particular about
details like yo yeah like your boy was
telling me like a D yell at the merchant
people because they were sending out
hats and they didn't have the right
amount of tissue right right right and
the hats or something like hair and then
I feel like even like an Steve Jobs
right I feel like they're like our
Instagram page is like you know it's
like yeah it's gotta fire it with you
know what I'm saying is is is that
something that starts with you or is
that something that like you like you
know that's like um you know I call it
like corporate culture it's like it's
like you know starts with me and my
managers and you know it just goes down
it's like this why Apple was so
successful is because Steve Jobs step
that standard you know and everybody
else fell into it that it's like okay
well this is what we're into this is how
we're operating is like we accept
nothing less than
I mean this level of everything across
the board and that's how you don't
listen
flip cracks - like um besides I know
that before tea giving you a cosign was
a big deal what was that like a non once
ago someone good um who is somebody that
is kind of like you've come across that
maybe surprised you that they're like
rockin with the movement that they're
with fanciers whether it's G or someone
that's just like you wouldn't
necessarily expect yeah that kind of
caught you off-guard
uh I mean Drake show love right yeah he
would watch my show every night when I
was on that Oh word yeah and that you
know I've met a lot to me just because
you know obviously I look up to him he
ain't everything he's done so much you
know so we're talking like towards the
end of it he was just like yeah you you
know you look like you've been out on
stages you know for years and years like
you know look like a star so you know
it's like it's just a little
it's not about again it's like I'm out
here on my own mission to you know name
but when you when you have people like
that system let you know you're on the
right path yeah what uh what music you
listen to right now man is there
anything that's in rotation yours yeah
shouts out to Tory Lanez man he Portland
oh baby yeah Izzy yeah Makonnen
obviously okay yeah yeah it's his part
next oh yeah yeah have you checked out
the launch out of Scott yeah oh you're
crazy yeah yeah he's that way he's got
it that's somebody else allowed you to
like kind of like have a similar you
know he didn't really have like I mean
he didn't really have a huge radio where
he doesn't have every not good you
didn't have you traded in and y'all each
kind of came out it's just about man
again it's like um hard work man you
know I that dudes a worker I know that
yeah he's in the studio all the time and
it's like if you put the work first and
you really just like build a culture
around the music you know
and a following and you know it's like
you it's where world where it's like the
powers that be and the gatekeepers don't
have all the power anymore but then you
see it's like you know you need to
balance it all out at the end of the day
yeah I think it's making like labels
will free re-evaluate how they they did
everything how was the BT cipher like
how long did it take you to write that
that verse like wow how nervous were you
going into that because you don't have
and I wasn't nervous I was just like you
know it was just like I got nervous when
I got there and I found out loaded Lux
was it mice like low rate because I you
know what I mean like I used to watch
all those smiley biddies on YouTube and
all that's what you know he's a monster
so I'm like man y'all put me in the side
for we loaded Lux and uh nah man I was
just like you know like whoever I'm in a
cypher web you know my first is still
hot but I still felt like whatever I
thought you got like no way there's a
few people got like really positive
feedback you want yeah yeah yeah I mean
I just go in there and just do what I do
and it's just like something like that
it was just another opportunity to uh
you know be in front of like a million
eyes you know they made a million
listeners like whatever everybody that
was you know watching the awards and
it's just about you know this is what I
do rise to the occasion and just make
the most of it
don't try and kill it that's what's up
man yo jay-z album is out go pick it up
I mean it's on on iTunes I think you got
a few radio records on this damn yeah I
think you know mmm it's still moving man
this legs so it's definitely like yeah
are you gonna get into movies bro I feel
like I want to man everybody always like
it I like talks like I feel like you
your videos I want to be I want to be a
superstar man as a day like you know I
want to be famous but but um yeah
Rosenberg Southside he he gave me my
movie my movie alter-ego name or what is
it I do decide to do movies I'm gonna go
by
Leonardo DiCaprio that's great
hey yo and and and I'm predicting this
now in the next year gez is going to be
smashing something famous and it's gonna
be all over TMZ yeah if he's not already
smashing something maybe it may be this
one you're I'm not investor
oh yeah no I didn't I need a couple of
big hits before I get into the a-list
place and when you hit that tee
absolutely all that man I'm coming for
you when I get that big hit dude I think
you hit Rihanna now and I'll Topeka I
think I might be able